[Music]
then you go big again with phase three
and it really kicks off with this film
and I was watching it last night and I'm
like you've got two sides of America
fighting together almost not hearing
each other out in 2016 it seemed like a
perfectly timed film in many ways well
that goes back to the Civil War coming
at a time in 2016 before an election for
us it was hey there's this great
storyline from the comics that pit Iron
Man and Captain America against each
other you could only do that storyline
when you'd had enough movies behind you
for that to mean anything to know enough
about Tony Stark's point of view to know
enough about Steve Rogers point of view
to believe they could face off with each
other that way and have it be
heartbreaking and emotional not knowing
of course that that when the film was
released the world would be in much
divided much the same way in the country
I think it's another one of those you
know even below the surface
you know we're influenced by real-life
as we as we make these as we make these
movies and I think that was one of the
reasons civil war touched such a nerve
is because we were looking at these two
people we loved in a way that you know
two halves of the countries that clearly
loved each other as a country as a whole
but facing off and how do we how do we
deal with these differences in a
superhero movie they punch the take with
new directors in this particular phase
it seems to take it to an even new level
obviously with Tiger continuing the
Russos but then you get a horror film
director come in and do dr. strange
right dr. strange was something we
hadn't really ever seen before remember
the first time you saw those special
effects I would do interviews like this
going back almost 10 years and people
would say well what down the line what
do you want to look what characters you
want to see come to screen would always
mention Black Panther would always
mention dr. strange because both of
those characters tap into entirely new
worlds within the within the Marvel
Universe and Doctor Strange the master
the mystic arts sorcerer supreme the
whole notion of sorcerers the whole
notion of of the multiverse and these
parallel dimensions is really important
in the comic storylines and we wanted to
be able to have access to that in our
stories and Doctor Strange was always
the notion of of being the endpoint to
that he also has one of the best origin
stories the notion of the mirror
to mention the MOA the notion of literal
mind-bending imagery which Scott
Derrickson from the very first meetings
would talk about you know wanting to
embrace sort of the psychedelic nature
of the of the time period in which
Doctor Strange was created in the comics
and it was in the visual effects reviews
in post-production after we'd shot most
of the movie that we really realized
that this would the mind-bending was
gonna work that this twisting of cities
being in a mere dimension that we'd
never seen before going into the
multiverse on what Scott would call the
magical mystery tour that the ancient
one sends Doctor Strange through and
culminating in a face-off against a bad
guy that you can't defeat you can't
fight punches aren't gonna work this
time and it really that even goes back
to the quantum realm in ant-man and
wanting to take audiences give audiences
a little taste of these super weird
mind-bending imagery that we could start
seeding into the MCU and then Scott blew
it out with a duck strange on the
subject of strange I'm wondering what
Tyco is what his pitch was to you but he
said I want to do Thor this way how did
he explain his vision take an amazingly
unique filmmaker we knew we wanted to do
a third Thor film that again as we had
done with caps third film and Iron Man's
third film go in a completely different
direction a totally unique case and we
had we had started to beat out the
notion of sacar and Hulk gladiator Hulk
being involved in Hell of being the
villain
and had internally at Marvel Studios
start to work on what that story could
be and we started meeting with
filmmakers tyka came in he made amazing
films in the past one of which called
boy we just loved and said well here's
the here's the guy because it's funny as
hell but also is moving and touching and
again we never want the spectacle or the
comedy or you know the outrageousness of
different planets and aliens to take
away from a core emotion and anti-coup
had done that he also was working on
another film with some he was finishing
another film that we hadn't seen and
didn't see until we were deep into prep
which was hunt for the world of people
which was another amazing film did he
have to make we'd go oh what are you
working to go just a little film
everyone oh okay I guess it's a some
small film
we're working on Ragnarok and we go to
see it we go this is amazing it's
incredible people think we're smart cuz
we hired the filmmaker of of welder
people but we hadn't seen it when we
when we cast him really boy that
convinced us and it was the meetings
with Tycho he always wanted to do a
movie like this he always knew he had a
bigger scale movie in him and I think he
trusted that we wanted to do different
things with the characters he and
Hemsworth had known each other in
passing before that and really excited
about the notion working together and he
worked on a sizzle reel that he that he
brought to that first meeting that was
hilarious and was perfect just clips
from other movies clips from the other
Thor movies cut together with his own
with his own unique take and tone and he
used the immigrant song
[Music]
and it just unlocked a whole new thing
for us we went this is this is it this
has got to be in the movie this one's
got to be in the marketing and of course
it was Spiderman was a special project
if it was kind of full circle you would
be an executive producer on require what
was it like to take that journey with
that character and I feel like in every
phase and in every project and as cheesy
as it sounds everyday at Marvel Studios
there's something amazing and special
that happens and makes me appreciate
being a part of it it was particularly
special getting to introduce the Marvel
Cinematic Universe version of spider-man
into Civil War because I was lucky
enough to be involved on the Sam Raimi
spider-man films and was low man on the
totem pole and just got to watch Sam
work and learned a lot from them and
when it came time Sony was talking about
additional spider-man films and doing
more it was it was really gracious of
Amy Pascal to hear me out
when I suggested incorporating him into
the into the MCU
and then doing an MCU spider-man film
with Tony Stark as his mentor and and
tapping into a spider-man that nobody
had seen before outside of the comic
book spider-man was not created in a
vacuum in a world without superheroes
spider-man was never the only superhero
in his in his universe he was part of
the Marvel Universe and in his early
comics he was nervous that could he he
wanted to join the Fantastic Four in
those early comics he grew up in a world
where Ironman would fly overhead and
where Hulk would smash cars in the
streets we'd never seen that version of
Peter Parker on screen before and it was
an unbelievable privilege to include him
in the in the MCU and one of those sort
of pinch yourself I can't believe this
is actually happening
moment what was it like seeing both
extraordinary critical and an audience
response to Black Panther but then to
see those numbers and and those kids
coming out of like Panther challenges
and in a way that it became more than a
film Ryan Coogler had done two amazing
movies when he when he agreed to do
black panther we had high expectations
we believed in the character introducing
him in civil war scene the audience
response to Chadwick as that character
we knew what Conda which we had been
seating in easter-egg since Iron Man 2
should be an amazing place and we knew
the notion of a movie
this scale featuring primarily African
and african-american actors had never
been seen before what Ryan Coogler ended
up doing and the way the audience
responded and the and the acclaim and
box office numbers behind it exceeded
even our wildest expectations
and it's a tribute to Ryan Coogler whose
brilliant brilliant filmmaker and a
humble humble man and who tapped into
very real questions that he had and
answered them in a cinematic way that I
think ranks is one of the best a best
way of filmmakers ever expressed himself
or his questions or his views on life in
a in a feature it was astounding to
watch an astounding to see him put it
together and the response to it I would
say we've been surprised at marvel
studios two or three times none more so
then then the amazing response in the
continued response to a black panther
what's your favorite place sequence it's
too hard for me to say what my favorite
one is because it's something that is so
personal to me I love those tags as a
kid I would always watch the end credits
on a movie hoping that there'd be
something I think it was you know Ferris
Bueller but coming out of shower and I
went whoa they're still there could be
more and usually there wasn't so I said
when we do our movies let's let's do it
it also allowed us to tell stories in a
unique way so I have great fondness for
the first one with Sam Jackson agreeing
to come in on a Saturday and shoot this
quick scene again with the promise that
maybe it could grow into into future
things and a promise to the fans that we
were going to try to build the Marvel
Universe on-screen I also love shwarma
and Avengers because I love seeing all
those characters finally United around a
table silently chewing and I also love
that that idea didn't come about until
the end final days on post they we
didn't shoot that scene until after the
premiere of Avengers which taught us if
there's a good idea you find any way
possible or impossible to get it in the
movie
you